in a session when we talk about support
for survivors we talk about children
that have been raped Angelina Jolie
mentioned this morning often in front of
family members we'll talk about rape of
elderly women and men we talk about
severe genital mutilation we talk about
gang rape and we also talk about
mutilation of pieces inside of us of
which we don't see the scars but they
can be just as much harmful
and we don't often talk about that but I
do really really think it's important
because it tells us something about the
extent of the support that is really
needed for survivors it can take years
if not generations and we will hear
about that in this session for those
harms to be repaired but it doesn't have
to be be that way and it should not be
that way
um I think the last 10 years since 2012
important strides have been made when it
comes to support for survivors I would
like to say that survivors are more
Central to the care that they are
entitled to
um I think it is more Community Based I
think it is more integrated in National
systems but the other side if you really
look critically
how much is there to celebrate because
how many victims are still left behind
and I just before we start want to give
you one example 2014 many of you will
remember the extremely high suicide
rates of girls that had been
abducted by Islamic State
the state that these girls were in and
then if you look back at the mental
health response over the years in all
fairness it has been patchy it's been
not sufficiently coordinated and
significantly underfunded with a
consequence now that many of these girls
are now women still suffering from
mental health problems affecting all
other parts of their life and when you
look back I really think it's right for
us to ask ourselves the International
Community why did we not do better why
did we not come in massively with
psychological support quality
psychological for support for every
woman girl boy that fell at the hands of
Isis and we haven't
what you would wish is that every child
had received the same care that he would
wish for your own child the best
possible care
talking about the best possible care I
would like to turn to your Royal
Highness and Dr McGregor your Royal
Highness you visited Ponzi not not long
ago and I would love to hear from you
both about the visit but also your views
on the best possible care
thank you very much Esther and ladies
and gentlemen it's an honor to be here
today with you all
um yes indeed I was recently in DRC and
had the huge pleasure of visiting pansy
Hospital pansy foundation and the City
of Joy now for those of you that haven't
been there the pansy hospital I have to
say I'm very pleased to say is
fantastically equipped with some amazing
technology
and some incredible surgeons who work
day and night to support many many
people that come through the doors the
level of of Medical Care there is really
unparalleled it is fantastic and they
try everything and anything they can to
literally put people back together again
um and I I saw in fact actually my staff
was slightly horrified because I ended
up in amongst a couple of surgeries that
were going on but um it really was
wonderful to be able to speak with the
surgeons and to understand better what
they were doing
um
moving that that is the medical care
that every single every single Survivor
should have the right to access
um but it is purely the lucky ones that
find themselves and I say lucky with a a
heavy caveat here
um but they are the more fortunate ones
that find themselves at pansy hospital
because they are going to get the best
care from the nurses and from the
surgeons and many of the people that I
met have had multiple surgeries over
many years
moving through from the medical side of
things into the foundation
this is where the more holistic side of
the Care is actually taking place this
is where
the staff are looking at understanding
how to not only put somebody back
together physically but mentally and
practically so you have all of the all
of the people there all of the clients
are being offered training so they have
a future it's not just a one-sided
approach and actually having met them
and seeing the many different
opportunities that they have which also
are coupled with psychological care as
well is giving them a potential uh which
if they are just purely treated
physically they may not have and of
course as we all know the the issue of
stigma
means that so many of them won't be able
to go back to their communities they
will not be accepted back into their
families
and therefore they have got a very Bleak
Outlook
alongside doing the Practical side of
things and the the teaching
we have children there's children at the
foundation
they call him Papa
um and for them it's hard how can they
understand what has happened to them
their future is very much in question
but when I tell you
that many of the staff at pansy
Foundation
have actually taken children on
themselves to look after them because
the reality
is that some of the mothers have
abandoned their children
now no one in this room and elsewhere in
the world can stand in Judgment of that
for those of us that have not
experienced the rapes that they have
experienced and the rejection that
they've experienced we must not stand in
Judgment of them but the reality is is
they leave the children behind and pansy
Foundation looks after them and as I say
many of the staff have actually taken
the Care on themselves
they also treat teach the the women
basic things like self-defense
if you if you give a
um somebody agency you give them respect
but you also want to give them power
and something as simple as self-defense
is empowering women
that they can stand up for themselves
so hopefully if they are if they are
attacked again because one cannot assume
that once they have left the foundation
that this may not happen again they may
stand a chance of protecting themselves
let's now move forward to the city of
joy
it's called the city of Joy because it
is one of the most joyful places I have
ever been
the the care
is based on love and respect
respect is something that has
it it doesn't cost anybody to respect
someone it costs nothing to love
somebody
and this is the premise that the city of
joy is based on and they work with these
incredibly damaged women
to give them self-respect
to give them life chances that they may
not otherwise have
and
they surround them with each other
because they also learn from each other
as well as the people that are working
there that give so freely of themselves
day after day
it is one of the most amazing visits
I've ever done I have every hope that I
will be returning in the future but it
was an amazing thing to do and I hope
that my description brings some of the
humanity into the room we've been
talking at a very high level in the last
couple of hours
but we have to remember that the
survivors are human
they need love they need respect
so really my next my question really is
to Dr McGregor I've tried to describe a
little bit of what they do there
how is it that you came about this
holistic model what is it that you think
is the essence of what you do
visitor
is
a position
s
the two wrong
which is
the problem physique
is
novel
foreign
problem physique
the fair secretary Medical
happening
is
Progressive
psychological
economic possessions
pass
is actually
thank you thank you very much thank you
your Royal Highness for highlighting I
think the compassion The Compassion of
quality Care protocol is one thing and
Advance all Protocols of thought are
followed of course but I recognize very
much what you're saying about it's this
compassion that really really makes a
very big difference
with that I would like to turn to First
Lady zelenska
thank you very much for being here
despite the situation in your country I
think I can speak for all of us in the
room
that we are incredibly grateful for the
effort for you to come here which I
think is a very important sign to
survivors and I would like us actually
to all give an Applause
[Applause]
first lady since Russia's War began in
2014 in the dombas and of course with a
recent Invasion and the continuing
Invasion reports have come out about
sexual violence being used as part of
the aggression
um what I find remarkable and I think we
will all share that is that the
Ukrainian government is there for
survivors and you're showing us that
despite an ongoing War a government can
be there for survivors but that is
extremely challenging can you tell us
please what are those challenges that
you're facing supporting survivors of
conflict-related sexual violence while a
war is ongoing in your country is under
attack at the moment
and thank you for your question I'll
speak Ukrainian because I will speak
about Ukraine
[Applause]
is
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
e
is
um
detino
collection is
foreign
absolutely
um
uh
narazi
is foreign
jorgeous
um
foreign
foreign
this crime truly does not have this
duration and it's important also for us
to understand that
sexually related crimes is not just
about violence or threatening in fact
this is another instrument
that they're using as their Weaponry
this is another weapon in their Arsenal
in this world conflict that's why
they're using this systematically and
openly they're very open about this that
is why it's extremely important to
recognize this as a war crime and to
bring all the perpetrators to
accountability because obviously such
crimes they can be just here or there
you know but if we see that this is
systematic because it is coming from the
top down and we see that the Russian
servicemen are very open about this they
talk about this over the phone with
their relatives you know that they they
the phone conversation that we managed
to capture and in fact
their wives the Russian servicemen's
wife are encouraging this man they say
go on rape those Ukrainian women just
don't share this with me just don't tell
me so they as if they have this fight
and that's why there has to be a global
response to this unfortunately such war
crimes will keep on going in the world
as long as
this service mean the servicemen think
that they can go without any
without any punishment
and that this can it be any chance of
impunity for them so truly I do hope
that there will be and there has to be a
response from the entire free world to
everything what's happening in Ukraine
now thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you first lady I think
the Applause speaks for for itself but
also thank you for
for highlighting uh how support quality
support for survivors can actually be a
condition for Seeking Justice uh I just
want to share with you I was in Ukraine
in May this year and we spoke to a lot
of survivors of the 2014-15 period and
what they were saying is we need to hear
the government we need to hear our
government that they're there for us and
that we are considered victims of war
and that is I think exactly what you're
doing through Justice through support
through reparations uh that is actually
something that victims around the world
should be hearing from their government
and in that sense you're really setting
a president thank you very much
foreign
it is such an honor to have to be
sharing this stage with you you are an
advocate for children born of war and
you and your organization the forgotten
children of War Association have been
fighting for many many years and I
remember a speech that you did in New
York and it made an incredible
impression on me because it was so
spot-on and if you allow me I will share
and you allowed me already before the
channel in all honesty I would like to
share the quote with you with the
audience
once while I was talking to my mother I
promised her that I would make this
world a better place for her and that is
why I'm standing here in front of you
today I hope that I'm on the right path
together with my friends also children
born of rape and children whose fathers
were members of peacekeeping missions I
built a better future for all of us who
are like us not only in Bosnia and
Herzegovina but all over the world
and that's exactly what you've been
doing
now thanks to your assistant advocacy
and that of your organization
um children
um that were born of rape have been
recognized this year by the government
in your country uh officially as victims
of war and that is a major achievement
be it 30 years after the war ended and
again that should be setting a precedent
for other countries
um but Anya please share with us what
what are some of the challenges because
this was not an easy achievement to to
to reach what are some of the challenges
for children born of War and what can be
done and by who yeah uh thank you thank
you very much for this opportunity to to
share our stories and to have a voice
in in in in this country uh yes when we
talk about challenges of the children
born out of War I have to say that we
are often called The Hidden population
because if people know that we are born
we would be exposed to stigmatization
and discrimination we are still exposed
to social contamination that can include
political and legal rejection so this is
the main challenge because because of
this precisely because of this our
mothers try to hide our father's
identities very wisely which makes it
difficult to map and gather children
born out of war in certain countries for
us in in Boston and Herzegovina
as you know we are very very neglected
population and I should emphasize that
our mothers are also exposed to double
stigmatization as a Survivor software
but also as a mothers
um without support women and girls
suffer significant psychological
physical social and economic effects of
the force motherhood
and I think that it is very important
that internet that Community
International Community
faced with this intergenerational
effects of the sexual violence that led
to the forced motherhood to conception
and birth of a child that this
consequence consequence of of that of
that violence I think that also we
should be aware that in the general lack
of the specific targeted National and
international policies and laws to
address the needs of the children born
out of four risk and harms would be
likely will be multiplied in the in the
lives of the children and become worse
I think also that it's important to set
that Global and National communities
must face the taboos and the
complexities surrounding the
reproductive violence and the force
motherhood because everything that our
mothers face with it's just passed on to
us their children children born out of
the out of the sexual violence
um also the constant practical and
normative marginalization of the
children born out of rape is a
significant obstacle to just to
sustainable and inclusive peace
reconciliation and transitional Justice
because we are very aware that
transitional Justice processes cannot
meet their goals if they don't recognize
nor enforce the rights of the children
born worn out of rape in the case of
Bosnia before Bosnia we had Norway and
Colombia that recognize children born
out of rape through the law
um Bosnia law was the first to to
respond to very recent recommendation of
the general U.N General Secretary and
also the recommendation of the human
rights treaty committees and the model
legislation written by a special
representative on sexual violence in
conflict and president said by
International courts to protect children
born out of four
these bodies emphasize and should do
more to support the fact that children
born out of War are category of the
victims that are not recognized their
needs are not addressed by this States
and I think that it should be more
imploring the states to recognize and
create the the legislation that will
include all risk needs and the issues of
of stigmatization
but from the perspective of the children
born out of for my personal perspective
and Association perspective I can tell
that this platform for Action showed us
once again that how much is important to
cooperate together because
[Music]
yummy thank you
because from from the beginning
um and um yeah it's it's always about
being together because this is not just
my problem I'm not okay I'm born out of
free but it's not just my problem it's
not just problem of our members it's not
just problem of of my mother this is a
really Global problem uh that should be
included and addressed in all political
structures especially in those who deal
with the question of the human rights or
the question of the support to survivors
because unfortunately in the case of
Ukraine and everywhere we can see that
war happening and will happen in the
future and if we can do something for
prevention let's do it because if our
common work can save just one life let's
let's not wait let's let's do it and
because of the full of room is uh very
full and there is so many organizations
I want to emphasize that in Bosnia we
screamed after 25 years of complete
invisibility this kind of screen was our
need we had to do that but thanks to
thanks to science thanks to research
from the children born out of four
Network thanks to cooperation with the
other associations especially in our
case thanks to operation with the trial
International we got the law now in
Bosnia you know this kind of cooperation
supporting the children born out for
help us to put our needs and risk on the
paper and transfer that into the words
of the law and on the end I'm sure when
I see a full house I'm sure that this
kind of cooperation exists in all other
different conflict or post-conflict
countries and I strongly strongly
recommend that we support encourage this
this cooperation because it's a life
changer my life has changed now and we
can do it for for more children out
there thank you
I know if you would allow me I just want
to amplify that call because personally
I'm still grappling with the fact that
in many countries children born of War
cannot be registered and if something is
within our power and within our legal
framework it is to register all children
give them an identity regardless of how
they've been conceived
thank you
so please to all the governments that
are here please let us work together
like Anya is saying to really get this
changed and make that a priority for
dinner for the next year I would say
thank you with that uh turning to the
International Community Lord Ahmad you
have been an advocate
ending Conflict for ending conflict
related sexual violence and in your role
you have traveled the world you have
seen many different forms of support to
survivors and it's actually I think
thanks to your personal commitment to
this to the issue and the plight of
survivors that UK continues to see this
as a priority which we are entirely
grateful for I would love to hear from
you what what are your impressions what
has what are the types of support that
have give left made most impression on
you and what can the International
Community do to step that up
well first and foremost what's made an
impression on me is this the panel now I
have the huge honor to be sitting with
today from the convening power of her
Royal Highness over a number of years in
terms of the personal motivation support
she's extended to me
Dr mcquagi what more can I say and I'm
proud that the UK government over
successive governments and you know what
recently I've been a few part of those
successive governments being provided
extended support to your efforts and
like her Royal Highness when we visit it
we saw directly the efforts and support
that you give
I often cost to yourself you know this
man Dr mcquagey has been subject not to
death threats actually they followed him
but he's gone back time and time again
and you put it on yourself I'm a member
of the government I'm a minister I'm an
advocate as you say but you know what
the best insights and the reason we do
this is all the survivors
you know it's important we look at
issues of reconciliation where we can
Bridge gaps between conflicting parties
and I know we've had some insightful
discussions this morning but I certainly
take the view you know I myself
am a child of the partition of the
Indian subcontinent
it was my visit to Bosnia
right at the start of my career in
finance
many many years after that conflict that
partition had happened that I came back
and discussed what I saw the people I
had met from the different communities
how family had turned on family
community on community Faith group on
faith group that after 40 odd years for
three occasions I saw a tear in my
father's eye and that was one of them
and that was the trigger that allowed
him to share what our family went
through in terms of the partition that
saw family split torture rape pillage
but what's important is how you bridge
gaps and Reconciliation that's why I'm
glad and having and yes you sitting here
we've met before later this afternoon
I'll be launching a real platform
committed to children born of rape and
sexual violence because it is not your
fault it's not fault of any child indeed
we should honor you we should salute you
and celebrate you because it's your
courage and advocacy which inspires
governments and it's right that we focus
on those issues
and to you first lady and what can I say
I've been I was sharing with you
yesterday I back in 2019 I was hugely
privileged and I said on a personal note
that I was the first minister to extend
congratulations to president zelenski
nor he not you not I indeed no one knew
what would unfail on Ukraine but again
the United Kingdom I'm proud to say has
stood firm in terms of our support for
you and we will continue to stand firm
on this but coming to your key point in
all of this I think it's important that
countries extend support in a structured
format ensure financing is there that's
why I'm pleased Esther we're supporting
the global survivors fund we need to be
coordinating activities that's why we
work hand in glove with key Partners un
agencies but most importantly Civil
Society organizations and partners but
it's also on governments to have those
tough calls and diplomatic engagement
when it's needed and that has been also
an important call that we can start
again having those candid conversations
because victims of these crimes the
survivors who have the courage not just
to be here but the most powerful
Advocates no government should need more
inspiring examples as to why this is
necessary and that bridging of those
dialogues is ensuring that in the future
we see reconciliation so I assure you
madam first lady from behalf of the
United Kingdom government that we stand
very firm in our support for Ukraine the
work we've done historically in places
such as Kosovo Bosnia the work we
continue to do in supporting yourselves
Dr mcquagi in what's happening in Congo
and we should never lose sight I was
asked a question that this isn't just
about live conflicts for the here and
now it's that conflicts that still
continue often as you rightly said Anya
there are issues under the radar and
it's our job through conferences like
this through bringing people together to
ensure those conversations can take
place those insightful discussions can
take place our historical past of any
country and I speak as a United Kingdom
minister
if reconciliation was not important we
would not be in the position we are
today there are things that have
happened in the past that the United
Kingdom is not proud of but it's for the
here and now and the future we build
together and that's why the work you do
Dr mcquagi the inspiration Anya you
provide the work your all highness you
have done in convening people frankly
it's an insight and to the survivors for
the work you do the inspiration you give
us there's a simple answer to your
question ultimately is that simply put
it's the right thing to do thank you
[Applause]
thank you Lord Ahmed for showing that
that commitment time after time again
and I think uh we uh spoke about all the
panelists but we haven't spoken about
you and I think your personal commitment
is uh speaks in everything that you say
and I would love that to be an
inspiration to all of the government
officials that are in this room to carry
this fight forward together with these
Advocates that I'm sure will continue to
serve the interests of survivors and
support for survivors to all of the
advocates in the room please keep
fighting keep fighting for justice keep
fighting for increased resources keep
fighting for safe access to care keep up
your fight and to all of the governments
here please hear their call and respond
with very bold action thank you very
much and have a good lunch
foreign
[Applause]
that is the end of the the morning
sessions
um I think